welcome to another episode of don't get
forked my name is Ryan I'm the club
manager here and this show is about
showing puzzles that all involve Forks
we have contestants come up a lot of
employees and club members will come up
they'll look at a puzzle and try to
figure out how the best way to not get
forked and just so there's no confusion
about what a fork is a fork is one one
piece attacks two other pieces any piece
can fork so all of our puzzles are
supplied by international Messer Eric
Rosen so thank you very much for that
and let's go to the board what we round
three of don't get forked with us is
Mario Roper chess club extraordinaire so
Mario your goal is to not get for it
okay it's White's turn to move and
you're gonna have 30 seconds to figure
it out okay you want to make the best
move on the board that allows you to not
get for it
are you ready so in three seconds you're
gonna turn to face the board and you
have 30 seconds to work you ready three
two one and go all right a lot of pieces
on the board here your goal is white is
to not get forked so first thing you
need to do is identify where the fork is
on the fork once you've done that then
you can figure out how to not get fork
apparently it's white it is white to
move and you have 15 seconds now
a lot going on the boys figure out where
to move to not get for it and I need an
answer now Quincy to go ahead and move
it on the board Queen c2 all right
that's one move you could make but here
is the fork Queen to a5 check loses the
knight
does that make sense do you see it now
yeah so let's go back a move now that
you know where the fork is what do you
should do now okay Bishop to Bishop d2 a
good move but you drop your knight so
good idea but you're almost there
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is stuff it is stuff chess is hard
some of us are good at some of us are so
it was apparently bit alright Bishop c1
that is correct
took me a minute
took you minutes dropped off all right
thanks for joining us on don't get
forked please like share and subscribe
to all our videos and if you have any
good fork puzzles please send them to
info at st. Louis chess club org thanks